next on encore book notes david
halberstam and the 50s
it lasts an hour
david halberstam author of the 50s
who was herb stemple and charles van
doren oh my goodness
they were almost one of the first
attempts of television
to go to casting in everything a shot
the idea the television everything it
did had to be cast and they were part of
the great quiz show scandal and what had
happened was that the the network was
the the producers were looking for a
whiz kid a kind of all you know a guy
who could answer every question and
herb's temple was someone who had this
brilliant mind i mean he had sort of a
encyclopedic knowledge and he went on
and he did very well they tested him
but
he was by their standards incredibly
unattractive and so they didn't know
what to do they had a kid who could
answer all these questions but there was
nothing win about it winning about him
so they decided to cast him as the
unlovable stemple and they cast against
him this great sign of a family the
vandoren family a great literary family
charles van doren and van doren was
elegant he was the son of a pulitzer
prize winning biographer the nephew of a
poster prize winning biographer he had
grace he had just enough diffidence that
he made him seem made it particularly
attractive on television because he
never seemed to want it so much
and the whole nation fell in love with
him it was the first i think real sense
to me the important thing about charles
van doren is it shows what television
could do that it could take overnight
someone who had never been on television
no one knew his name and within two
weeks make him into a national hero
someone who could run for the presidency
almost like the perot phenomenon and
they did it and they brought vandoorne
out and the whole nation fell in love
with him what year was this
1957 i believe although the scandal i
think breaks later on
and
the problem is
it's rigged
so the country is falling in love with
vandoorne it wants vandor and graceful
charming and winning to beat the dreaded
herb stemple who is
considered to be sort of unattractive
lower class whatever and vandoorne keeps
winning and winning and winning
and what the country doesn't know is
that both temple and vandoren have been
given the answers to the questions and
it's all manipulated that it's a fix the
network was nbc the program's title was
it wasn't 60 it was 21 it was 21. but
there was a program called the
sixty-four thousand dollar question it
began it was a sixty-four thousand
dollar question and then in the final
manifestation it was
21 with van doren and stempel and a guy
named dan enright as the fixer and a guy
named al friedman as his subfixer and it
led to congressional hearings on it in
which finally van doren who had
protested his innocence protested his
innocence protested in innocence had to
go before the country sign of this great
family
and say
what i did was wrong it was rigged in
fact a lot of my life has been rigged
and fixed it was a traumatic moment for
a lot of people a lot of people said
this is the end of innocence have we
corrupted everything i mean is there
anything left that is pure in america it
was a shattering moment for many
americans particularly because that
noren was an intellectual all-star
coming from that family with that charm
whether i mean mark van doren his father
was arguably one of the greatest
teachers and english professors of his
time and here was charlie who was going
to follow in his footsteps and teach
english at columbia and then was pulled
aside from a salary of 3 500 a year by
the promise of this enormous money
in this quiz show
now i noticed in the back where you list
all the people you interviewed that you
interviewed herbs temple but you did not
interview charles van doren well i wrote
him a note and you know he's not
available for interviews and he has made
that pretty clear i think it's such a
painful thing in his life
that he's never quite come to terms with
it i wrote him a note saying listen i'd
like to interview you i think that what
happened with you is has a broader
resonance that really what it shows is
that television will cast everything the
president's a race for the presidency
television has to have casting it's
drama it isn't just politics has to be
not just politics but entertainment and
i think what happened with you and
stemple is the great first great example
of it and i got back a very nice very
polite letter saying well i don't know
if you're right or not
but i'm not giving interviews it's a
very polite letter but it said nada
and he moved to chicago and went to work
for mortimer adler yeah mortimer adler
with the great books series was a family
friend and he went out there friend of
mine
who saw him there i asked a friend of
mine who was an editor of a chicago
paper what he was like because in a city
like chicago the journalists and writers
tend to hang out together and i said was
he part of your group and he said no on
a very rare occasion i would see him and
he struck me as someone living in exile
from another country very sad phrase
he would write books that are still
books of some distinction but he cannot
promote them the way i'm promoting my
book now because he knew that if he went
on any kind of television show they
wouldn't ask about whatever book it is
great thoughts
of the western mind
it would be the first question would be
what about the quiz show scandal so he
was never able to promote his own books
was the 21 program and the quiz show
scandal
uh port 10 of what we've gotten since
1957 on television well i think it was a
reflection a of the power of the medium
the country's much more skeptical now
there was an innocence about television
television was brand new anything that
worked worked and stunned people i mean
it was sort of you know when they first
did the sixty four thousand dollar
questions and it was sponsored i think
by revlon you couldn't buy a revlon
product the next day i mean brevan
doubled its
percentage of the market practically the
other companies that were in the same
cosmetic field went way down and in fact
one of one of the other companies had to
write a letter to its stockholders
saying you know because of the
extraordinary success of our rival
company with a quiz show our stock went
down this year it really changed
everything i think it was a portent of
how television casts everything that
there is it wants good guys and bad guys
60 minutes which is arguably a very good
show
but it's also like a western i mean
there's mike wallace wearing the white
hat and whoever he's interviewing has
got to have a black hat on i mean
television loves it it doesn't like
complexity it likes simplicity good and
evil
where do you live
new york city really near lincoln center
in a lovely apartment that was once
designed for artists it's a block called
the cafe des artists block and the main
room is
theatrical it's two floors and with sort
of a little
almost rabbit water and other rooms off
it it's a wonderful privileged life you
know being a book writer i'm about to be
60 and next birthday and i go out and i
write books i live a good life and i i
can have both my private life
and my professional life in a way that
an anchor man
on television or a superstar television
reporter can't i mean there's a
wonderful level of privacy
and a wonderful level of engagement in
the society i have the best of both
worlds i counted in the front of the
book 12 books plus this one yeah 13 i
think it is now and i've been on a very
nice roll because i think
all the last eight starting with the
best and the brightest have really all
done well i mean they've made
best seller list and it's allowed me to
have the the ability to go out and write
books that sometimes four or five years
sometimes take four or five years like
going in and going to a university you
enter a door
one day and then four years later you
come out you've sort of got your
intellectual degree from it and you've
learned so much more and yet you make
enough money to live in new york city
that's really that's very very lucky
were you born
i was born in the bronx my father
was a doctor my brother and i were
probably two years younger
than
we should have been because of the
depression we're really depression
children he was born in 32 i was born in
34 and about the time that our father
was going to make some money i think he
graduated my father was a veteran of
world war one he'd been a poor kid
immigrant son from
small town in pennsylvania and
about that he graduated from medical
school in 1929 having been encouraged
by the field hospital doctors in world
war one to go back and study medicine
that he could be more than a medic and
he graduated in 29 and he graduated in
the depression about the time he was
finally going to make some money
world war ii came along at the age of 46
he went back in the service so we left
new york and the bronx then and we we
moved all over our
our main home from then on was a little
town in northwest connecticut a mill
town called winstead i'm one of the few
people who has known ralph nader since
he was eight years old when we were in
the fourth fifth sixth seventh eighth
grades together and we lived in el paso
then we went from winston to el paso to
father follow my father then to austin
texas then to rochester minnesota and i
think it was i mean it was difficult
going to a new school all the time
but it also gave you a sense of the size
of the country and it allowed me when i
finally graduated from college and went
on to journalism to be more fearless and
more adventurous in the assignments i
took on
you mentioned ralph nader in your book
in regard to the corvair
what why did you write about the corvair
in the 1950s well just as a symbol of
one of the things that the book is about
is it really says that when you put down
the book
i wanted people to know about the 50s
but i also wanted to know why the 60s
happened when you put down this book you
should be able to say to yourself ah
now i know
why the 60s happened and so by doing the
roots
of
the 60s i dealt lightly with the coming
of ralph nader and the corvair i mean
the building of the corvair when gm
begins to cheat just a little on the
roller bar the roll bar when it you know
should have the balance and for about 18
they take out something that makes the
car more stable you begin to sense the
power of the accountants on a car that
gm doesn't really want to do anyway
because it's a small car and it thinks
small cars small profits so it cheats on
this car as it shouldn't cheat and out
of that you get these terrible lawsuits
and these terrible terrible accidents
did
some americans
resent the little vw beetle running
around because it was german
i don't think it was that it was german
i think when there was resentment of
things german post-war and there was i
mean in the early 50s you began there
was sort of anything german our
attitudes were still
some people were still formed in uh
world war ii anything german was bad i
don't think we're as tolerant yet um the
resentment was more towards a mercedes
benz i mean it wasn't towards a little
uh little dinky bug-like car i think the
resentments that the beetle brought were
the resentments of detroit towards a car
that was small that didn't and and the
worst thing about the the beetle was
that the people were buying it could
afford cadillacs that's what drove uh
detroit crazy i mean the people who were
buying the beetle were these scientists
and
college professors and they were the
affluent people of the upper middle
class by all rights they should have at
least had a buick
and probably a cadillac and instead
they're buying miniature miniaturized
transportation a much smaller part of
their budget and instead they're going
on skiing vacations or going on vacation
to uh
to europe they're not using their
disposable income the way a good loyal
true american should back in the 1950s
which is to maximize their
transportation to have two or three of
the biggest cars you can get
by the way as you can see here
i'll hold it up so the camera you can
see it there is no index in this book
in order to find out what's in each
other
you got cheated there is an index in the
book really yeah you got cheated i'm
very sorry we will replace this with a
hand signed book
and there is an index they gave you a
flawed copy it probably makes it all the
more valued you can probably say
collector's items the collectors are you
can probably auction this book at a at
an auction with your notes on it and
probably be worth a great deal i will
personally get you a book with an index
i really wasn't maybe before the day is
out i really wasn't complaining because
it forces you quickly to learn what's in
the book so you know what you really
should have an index on a book like this
all right 40 chapters 800 pages 730 in
terms of the book the notes the index
the invisible index or the non-index and
then the author's notes take up another
50 or 60 pages i but seventh we tried we
wanted to bring the book in at under 750
pages in terms of the manuscript itself
we had to cut 500 pages out my wonderful
editor doug stumpf cut out and this was
really stuff that was good i mean there
was a portrait of rocky marciano as the
last white heavyweight fighter sort of
rocky before rocky we had to cut it out
really good stuff what else was cut out
we cut out a section on the catcher in
the rye as an early um
rebel we cut out longer chunks of some
of the stuff that made it we just had to
cut out a lot of really good stuff you
talked much about the airplane anywhere
there is some sense in there i think of
the jet airplane the coming of the jet
planes and we talk oh i'll tell you one
plane that is in there which is
brilliant is the u2
i mean here is this great spy plane that
they do almost door to door in 90 days i
mean from the time they
vision the idea american science and
technology and
aero and aeronautical engineering is so
good that from the time they
have the idea for a spy plane that can
fly at 75 000 feet to the to the
operative
model takes only three months you
couldn't do that today
where were you uh in 1950
in 1950 i we had moved briefly back to
westchester county i was still in high
school
in new york we moved there because my
father had come back from the war and we
briefly lived there 1951 i graduate from
high school in westchester
the korean war is on but my generation
we had we had in effect
draft deferments based on class in the
korean war without anybody knowing it if
you went to college your draft board
left you alone no matter whether you
were going to be a scientist or not we
were 2s so korea was the coming of a
class line in who fought for our country
we didn't even realize it at the time
and so i had the benefit of that and i
went on a public high school kid to
harvard not a very good student but
editor of the harvard crimson managing
editor and i graduated in 1955.
so i went so that i'm a child of the 50s
really
when did you get the idea for this book
well i've had it for a long time because
i really don't i wanted to do an
autobiography but i don't think
journalistic autobiographies are any
good
i mean you know
someone says you know writes a biography
six presidents who have known me and six
presidents i have known and it turns out
he hasn't known these presidents very
well
it turns out you know you you write
about being overseas in your overseas
incarnation i was a young reporter in
the congo
i don't really remember much about the
congo except the difficulty i had filing
from the telex i mean it's all it's not
a clear memo memo memor
memory i don't have
clear memories of many congolese or now
zyrian people so i think journalistic
memoirs and they go
i did not know general de gaulle very
well and he he and i were not intimate
but i'd like to think that we had this
warm respectful relationship and one day
after one of his press conferences the
general came over to me signaled that he
wanted to talk and he said to me mr
albestam
i thought your question today was
beautifully phrased and your friends was
parfait
that's your relationship with general de
gaulle so this was a way of doing an
autobiography
that which formed me that which i lived
through
without having to go through the boredom
of my own life
did you select the way that the book was
laid out and the way the chapters
followed yeah i envisioned the book six
years ago another reason i wanted to do
it
was that i though the last long book i'd
done was the reckoning which was the
story of the american core
economy
coming under pressure becoming
vulnerable from challenges from the
challenge of the japanese and so i
wanted to look at america
when it was rich in a world that was
poor when everything seemed to work so
these were the dual things and i had a
vision of the book about six or seven
years ago before i started out
and it was this vision i mean there
would be sections on television
sections on the affluence sections on
the mccarthy and period and if possible
near the end of the book they would
begin to twine together they would as
one person said they would braid so that
you would have television and then you
would have civil rights and then late in
the book television would be covering
civil rights that's what i had i wanted
to show the impact among other things of
television on the society so that you
get the speeding up i mean i not only
have general motors and it's supreme
affluence but late in the book i have a
wonderful chunk i think
on jerry schnitzer and kenzinger jones
doing these astonishing commercials for
those chevrolets that are beautifully
done that are like norman rockwell going
to television
chevy in the heart of the american
culture and so we have the ability now
to sell over television the coming of
this powerful instrument that comes
right into your home not just in
politics but as a salesperson and it's
and so i tried to i had that in my
vision that these that these different
parts would begin to braid together
were you working on any other book in
the middle of trying to do this yeah i
did um
i mean i think that book was this book
was about six years long and in the
middle of it i did a small sports book
summer 49 which had great fun which was
by the way informed by this book because
this is a book on the coming of
television to a society and the summer
49 is on the last radio era in baseball
you know before big money before
television when you have these when you
hear a game on the radio and you form a
mythic vision of a dimaggio or a
williams they live larger because you
create the myth for them in in the
fantasy of your mind so that was
a
and then i did another i did that book
in the middle of it i did a very small
book called
the next century which was an essay
based on some of the things that i had
learned in doing the reckoning about
america
in jeopardy
why did you start in the first chapter
with a fairly long discussion about his
chambers alger hesse whitaker chambers i
think it's the shadow
of
these a case like that and it was not
just his chambers there were other
things the rosenberg's judith coplin
what i wanted to show was that here was
america that was very affluent in this
post-war era
rich as i say you know in a world that
is poor but the anxiety
of living in a divided world with the
communists at a time of
nuclear weapons where both sides have
nuclear weapons and then thermonuclear
weapons and both sides have delivery
systems
which is even creates greater anxiety
because the things that have always
protected us are security blankets the
two oceans
no longer matter because you can deliver
the ultimate weapon by jet
or by rocket the anxiety that causes and
in addition what i wanted to show was
that i thought that the mccarthy period
and i think this is if the book has in
effect a revolutionary idea and i don't
know if it's revolutionary but i believe
from my research that the mccarthy
period begins and gets into the virus a
virus into the bloodstream
of the society
when the republicans lose to truman in
48. they've lost four times to roosevelt
they are chomping at the bit they are
already afraid that they are going to be
a permanent minority party but they
believe that dewey will win
when the little haberdasher as they
thought he was and we know now is an
extraordinary american politician an
extraordinary american
beats dewey and they have lost five
times in a row the fear that they are a
permanent minority party
is very real and in fact there's a very
early in the book i think it's about
page four i quote a meeting of thomas e
dewey going to see dwight eisenhower and
asking him to run because he's this
independent who's above politics and
dewey is saying we have eisenhower's
notes of it you know
a republican can't be elected anymore
because the democrats demographically
because of roosevelt have so changed the
nation that you have a plant in effect
where there are 500 people five people
are managers and they wear suit and tie
and they vote republican and 495 are
blue collar and they're democrats and
they vote for the democrats the
demographics are against us
it is this fear
of being a permanent minority party that
i think begets the mccarthy period
because for the first time they have to
seize on another issue
you know pure economic issues they're a
minority but if they seize on this issue
and that is
subversion in government the idea that
our government has been soft on the
communists or even hand in hand with it
that we have been subverted here
domestically by our own people that will
get them back in and that issue begins
only
after dewey's defeat dewey runs a very
honorable campaign he does not use smart
he does not use the anti-communist he
does not use softness on communism that
stuff comes after his defeat and even as
someone as elegant as robert ate taftan
we've really not had many senators
better more elegant more distinguished
finally says to mccarthy joe mccarthy
joe keep going if one case doesn't pan
out try another i.e put the democrats on
the defensive use this issue to keep
them on the defensive let me read this
uh
sentence
uh the setting was this august the 3rd
1948 house committee which included a
large number of the most unattractive
men in american public life bigots
racists reactionaries and sheer buffoons
held hearings in which whitaker chambers
not only said that he himself was a
communist but that there was a communist
group in the government in the late 30s
and that alger his was a member of it
i mean let me just do that again bigots
racist reactionaries and sheer buffoons
who were you talking about about the
house on the american activities
committee the one
solid person on that committee was a
young congressman from california named
richard nixon i mean you just couldn't i
mean they were known for their
buffoonery nixon was intelligent
serious smart he was by far the most
reliable member of the committee he was
being fed stuff by aj edgar hoover he
had access to the fbi files but he was
he performed very skillfully in the his
keyrings i mean he did not by the way
have a bad press in his series he would
later claim the press is against me
because of this that's not true
the press was against him finally for a
variety of other reasons but in his case
you really had a buffoon a bunch of
buffoons on that committee and when in
fact when when
hiss made his first presentation because
he was so elegant and so sophisticated
the epitome of harvard harvard law
school and the establishment and
chambers who was a brilliant but really
sort of disheveled man with a very
bizarre past most of the committee
members said let's get out of this thing
that guy hiss looks terrific um
let's get rid i mean i don't like the
look of chambers they were saying it was
only nixon and i think in part because
he was being fed by the hoover people he
knew a bit more than the others said no
let's stay on it and he noticed that
there was an odd
there was a certain quality to his
to his denial that they were really kind
of
calculated they were not complete
denials there were little phrases in
there that protected him from complete
denials and he pursued the case and more
and more stuff came out and it turned
out that you know two juries in effect
believe that chambers rather than hiss
was telling
the truth i mean in the first case you
had a hung jury i think it was eight to
four
for conviction of perjury against his
and the second jury was
voted to convict alger hiss is still
alive i think he still died yes and you
write that even though last year there
was a spurt of information coming out of
the soviet union that suggested that he
might be innocent that that was proved
wrong also yes i think there was a there
was what happened is volca ghana of
lieutenant general the head of the kgb
file sort of said alger hiss you know
you're we've checked it out and you're
free man and then
and apparently he was told
to uh that by people representing his
that this was a very old man and he's
near death and it would be a wonderful
thing if he could
let him go not knowing that this was
still a burning issue in america so he
did this and of course nobody has really
gone through all the files the files are
probably incoherent and all over the
place so he then
having started a firestorm of protest
among the pro chambers anti-his people i
mean george will and others wrote about
it
he backed down very quickly and said
that in fact he had not had access to
all the files
looking back
from where you said what do you think of
the whole his chambers thing
well i think they're missing pieces
nobody really knows all i am inclined to
believe that his
in
obviously his new chambers despite his
denial of denials i am inclined to
believe that either his was a member of
the communist party or is it protecting
his wife who was i mean there's
something there there's just an awful
lot of stuff that is there that doesn't
go away i mean obviously as well
chambers is incredibly conspiratorial
and living this life of the double age
and
deep in his own paranoia but also a
brilliant man i don't think what was
made the case was made out to be in
effect the lesson for a generation is if
hiss would then symbolize the entire new
deal and the end of the new deal i don't
think it's a symbolic case but it was
made in his was made into a symbol which
i don't think he was
one of the things that you know it pops
up in your book periodically is how you
often mention along the way you say that
buttercup chambers was a homosexual
you say later on they talked about
tennessee williams being a public
homosexual uh i think jack kerouac and
high percentage of the beach were uh
but coming today reading about this in
1993
this was back in the 1950s was that an
issue back then well i think there was a
lot of back channel word about chambers
and one of the reasons that his
credibility at the time was relatively
low was that they had a lot of stuff in
the file that showed that his
life you know had had a darker side and
that certainly for someone like j edgar
hoover made him a less than perfect uh
witness i mean hoover with his own
homophobia was uh not going about pin i
mean he made
whitaker chambers was hardly a white
knight
to the people who would have wanted him
to be one i mean he was there was a
quality of so much pain and anguish in
his life that they were wary of pinning
their great hopes on him intellectually
as it turns out and you can read his
book witness is a brilliant
mordent study of human frailty whitaker
chambers yes book is a great book
but let me ask you about this so you
talk about the homophobia of j edgar
hoover then you kind of refer to the
fact that he and clyde tolson were what
well there was this odd thing they were
always together they were each other's
best friends i mean i don't think
anything ever happened i don't believe
these stories you know that they have
now about
hoover dressing up in drag i don't
believe it for a minute i mean j edgar
hoover's whole life
was devoted to getting sturdy stuff
gossip on other people the last thing in
the world he was going to do was provide
gossip for his enemies i mean he just
wasn't going to do that but there was
this odd relationship between him and
tolls and they were together at every
meal they went to work together you know
they ate alone nobody else you know
nobody else need apply the two of them
eating lunch and dinner
almost every day of their life i mean it
was an unusual friendship i mean i don't
think anything was consummated but it
really did make people talk about them i
want to come back to uh television and
politics in just a second
if someone were to follow you around
over the last six seven years
and watch you put this book together
what would they see i mean for instance
do you all these interviews you listen
back do you go to them personally do
them on the phone where do you write
well i think most interviews should be
done personally i think it's great fun i
think you interview better when you see
someone i think they give you as you
show up you get
a higher validation you've made the
effort to come to your house you see
people it's more fun the fun isn't doing
the interviews
and so i mean you often do follow-up
interviews you know hey you see someone
he i forgot to ask you such and such
they would see me go to the library a
great deal for this and read books or
check out well in new york there's a
wonderful library that i love going to
called the new york society library it's
a small private library 79th between
park and madison it's wonderful it's not
very expensive and while i do go to the
new york public library there's
something about the new york society
library that i really loved
a friend of mine named eli zabar
runs a wonderful little food shop most
expensive food shop in america i mean
probably a roast beef sandwiches about
200 these days but eli is over there at
80th
8th and 81st in madison so if i work
till about 2 30 i often go and have a
light lunch and i can get cappuccino
there and then the ui will come over and
talk with me so we have a very nice i
check in with a friend i have this great
cappuccino and a light lunch maybe a
couple salad and i've had five days five
hours in the library five hours in the
library is just wonderful i mean it's
always an adventure it's like eating
salted peanuts you never know what
you're going to get next
what do you write i write
um at home my um
we have a small in addition to our
regular apartment we have a very small
apartment in the back
and my wife wanted to get me out of the
main house where i work because she
thought the steam and angst that came
out of my ears and nose and
during the day while i was working there
significantly detracted from her calm
and her control of space so he got this
back apartment which is really quite
nice and i go up there and i get up in
the morning when i'm writing if i write
in the morning
and i get up and i have a very lazy
cappuccino
i love the cappuccino and a very light
breakfast and then about 9 30 or so i go
up to what i call the cage which is
where i write i've got a nice little cd
player sometimes i play the blues or
sometimes it's mr vivaldi or mr mozart
in there and then i work for about five
hours and when it's done there's some
exercise machines there and whatever and
some books and it's a nice place but
when it's done i want to get out of
there and gene my wife says come on why
don't you you're going to read why don't
you read in the office and i said it's a
cage when i'm there and it's exhausted
i'm writing i'm writing everything i
think about in that office is writing
the moment my writing for the day is
done i want to get out i want to be here
i want to be with you or whatever i
don't the pressure of writing
and being in that room is so great that
when it's over i don't want to be in the
room i can't relax almost until i'm out
of the room what are you right on
i used to be a
an old-fashioned
type writer hunting back i never went to
an electric typewriter and then about
10 years ago friends convinced me to try
word um processors
and it has liberated me and probably
doubled my productivity i mean because
it just
it's a great instrument with which to
rewrite you know to clean and the old
days you made one typo and you typed it
i had to retype the whole page because
of a typo i make a lot of typos i'm a
fast hunting
pac-man i make a lot of typos
now i just it's like playing pac-man
cleaning up the typos it's it's so it's
really made my life a lot easier and
it's really damn near doubled my
productivity
are you already writing on another i'm
going to do i've got two books i'm
working on i'm very excited about one it
will be a i do you know i did summer 49
and that's the beginning of the yankee
dynasty and then i'm going to have a
book on the cardinals and the yankees in
the world series of 64 which is sort of
the end of it and the rise of a great
saint louis team with gibson and flood
and brock and mcarver and white good
characters and then i'm going to do a
book i was a reporter in nashville
tennessee 33 years ago the first sit-ins
started there and it was a very
interesting group of young black kids i
was the reporter from the then liberal
tennessee which would cover stories like
this as a lot of newspapers did not and
it was triumphant
terrifying i mean the fear the violence
whatever i covered it i was a year older
than they were they came finally to
trust me
and i've had friendships and
associations for example with john lewis
who's a congressman marion barry was
part of that group and i want to track
their lives then and now i think it's
going to be a wonderful book
john siegenthaler
al gore
lots of other names
south westfeld it's a great paper it was
a great nashville tennessee nashville
tennessee and i'd worked for a year in
mississippi i got out of college in 1955
and i had been managing at the harvard
crimson and i wanted to be a journalist
really badly but i also and you know and
i you know you're managing out of the
harvard crimson that's this year that's
pretty good that's you're putting out a
paper six times a week for very
sophisticated audience but i knew i was
incomplete i knew i didn't know enough
about talking to people i had to learn
how to go out and interview ordinary
people i had to do an apprenticeship i
decided this myself because i think i
could have gotten a job in new york or
washington and if i was going to do is
the year after brown versus board of
education if i was going to do an
apprenticeship
why not do it
in the south
why not in the deep south
why not in mississippi which was the
deepest of the deep south the most
recalcitrant state
and there was a guy at harvard named tom
carcell who was a neiman fell you know a
35 year old journalist and he said he
was going to be the editor of this new
liberal paper in jackson and he said
he'd hire me terrific everybody we
graduate all my other friends on the
crimson are going off to road
scholarships or different fellowships
i'm going to i'm going to mississippi i
get down there he's not working for the
new liberal paper he's working for the
old racist paper the jackson daily news
i've got everything i own packed in my
46 chevy what do i do they find me a job
as
one reporter on the smallest daily in
the state of mississippi the west point
mississippi daily times leader and i go
there and i work 46 dollars a week 45
plus a dollar because i
extra because i cover the kiwanis club
every wednesday
greatest experience probably of my life
fresh out of harvard jewish
you want to be in a different
environment my friend you are in a
different environment and i learned a
lot i learned how to deal with ordinary
people to listen to them to see people
the value in people who didn't who
didn't agree with the same things i
agreed and how they worked what their
lives were and from there i went to four
wonderful years on the nashville
tennessean
again honing my skills learning to
interview people i looked around i knew
i wasn't as good a leg man
digging so i figured out who the good
reporters on the tennessean were and i
just watched them every day and every
night i went out to dinner with him and
i said how did you do that how did you
do that when i got out of there after
that five year apprenticeship
i was a really good reporter i mean
everything had come together for me
for those people who want to know
whether they should buy this book
if you don't mind i want to
tick off a lot of different names and
give just 30 seconds okay and then they
can get the rest of it but there's so
much that it might be helpful uh betty
ferness well she's wonderful she was the
westinghouse lady she'd been a b actress
was doing some out in hollywood was
doing some small television work in new
york
she watched the coming of early
television they had all these people who
couldn't who were trying to display
their things couldn't do it she became
the lead the lady from westinghouse she
was smart attractive women liked her men
liked it but women liked her as well you
could almost chart the coming of the
super appliance it begins she's twice as
big as the refrigerator then year by
year in the 50s the refrigerator sort of
begins bigger and bigger gets bigger and
bigger and dwarfs her
she would go out to
do the conventions in 52 and 56 and they
had to do stuff live she'd have 60
different outfits that she'd keep
changing so that she would never look
boring and she became as famous as
walter crockett as anybody on those
shows and she is a lovely lady and what
television caught about her was that she
was nice and it wasn't by mistake that
men liked her and women didn't feel
threatened by her because she's a good
person alfred kenzie
great american
distinguished scientist
ultimate square the squares man a
professor of zoology i mean a man who
had the greatest collection of bugs
midway in his career
his students come to him and say we
don't really know much about sex so he
starts giving a course on sexuality
and it becomes the most you know because
it's a great guarded secret in the 40s
and suddenly it's the most popular
course at indiana university and with
that knowing that these students don't
know the most elemental things about sex
he gets into interested in sexual um
studies and he begins to do these
classic studies of sexuality which i
mean taking the mo the darkest subject
covered with the most superstition and
trying to ventilate it what are our what
are our sexual habits you know what do
we really do how much experience have we
had and he publishes first the sexual
habits of the american male and then
later the female and is pilloried for
having done
a brilliant scientific study instead of
even i mean liberal
ministers heads of the universities like
princeton attack him saying he should
attack his own findings i mean it's this
is wrong i mean he's publishing this
stuff and it's wrong he was a brilliant
brilliant scientist a truly
revolutionary man betty goldstein oh
well that's the maiden name of the lady
who wrote rather large on the decade to
come her name later became betty friedan
she was bright summa [ __ ] laude went to
greenwich village was filled with the
excitement of being a young reporter in
the village then she marries begins to
have children is pulled to the suburbs
and she's suddenly beginning to wonder
is this all there is to my life in 1957
she starts doing a study for her 15th
reunion at smith she starts sending out
a questionnaire to other people and she
finds out from all the other smith women
of this generation that they share many
of them i won't say all many have the
same despair frustration and this
question is this all there is to life us
sitting out in the suburbs driving
station wagons taking care of
our children or is there going to be
something more out of that comes the
feminine mystique a seminal book
a couple of weeks ago this lady died and
you write
a couple pages on her i think pat nixton
i think she's heartbreaking she has a
childhood so harsh it is dickensian it
is hard i mean as if she lived in the
time of charles dickens she hard to
imagine anybody
was so difficult of life and you know
her mother who's the one person she
really loves dies when she's young her
father dies she raises her brothers
cooks for them takes keeps house cleans
and then goes off and studies herself
puts herself through school i mean
utterly admirable really beautiful when
she's young eventually marries richard
nixon i don't think she really at first
when they dated she was not that
enthusiastic about going out with him
but he was nothing if not persistent and
i think he was the one way she could get
out of whittier california ask if this
was new information you interviewed jim
bassett yes who was a press secretary to
richard nixon
and you talk in in this book about the
fact that richard nixon treated her
differently in private
than in public is that now i don't i
mean i think it's
been there before but i think it's used
in this book as i've brought it out a
little bit more in this book i think you
know
i think from almost the checkers speech
on people were astonished by how when
they were in public
she was the great prop to him she would
look up adoringly at him and but then
they would get back in the plane and
they'd sit separately as if in two
universes and they would never touch and
i think when he had his farewell speech
you know when he was driven out because
of watergate he talks about his mother
at great length his father at great
length and how you know in this very
sentimental moment and what wonderful
people they were he never mentions her
and she's the person who's gone through
more agony because of his career than
anyone else i think i think she never
wanted a career in politics she wanted a
nice suburban life with the children
with a kind of middle class affluence
and security that she had been denied
herself did you see the funeral by the
way i saw just clips brief clips of it
there was a rather emotional former
president nixon i just wondered if you
had any sense as to
why after all these years he would
be so emotional in public over this i
don't know maybe it finally came home to
him how much she had given
and how much
a higher price she had paid i think for
his career i mean i think there is she's
really fascinating she's a classic wife
of the 50s stoic do what your husband
wants even if it's not what you do go
along with it um that's your role
you would not find many political wives
like that today
ozzie and harriet
ricky and david well they're the symbol
of america in the 50s i mean when people
talk about america
in the 50s and they talk about it as an
innocent time they think of those early
shows leave it to be beaver father knows
best ozzie and harriet and they were the
all-american family
and yet
um the 50s were not that innocent i mean
even in this all-american family you
know no one knows what ozzie does but
he's a good easy relaxed guy
in real life ozzy was a workaholic
quite authoritarian really dictatorio
wrote directed
and produced all these shows used his
own children in the shows i mean and
really in some ways you could argue took
away part of their childhood
particularly with ricky took away the
one thing that really mattered his music
and put it into the show so that you
know ricky i think was always unhappy
with that you could make the argument
that in the end the nelsons were
something of a dysfunctional family even
though they were the ideal to all those
other american families back in the 50s
i saw kevin's wilson listed as one
person that you interviewed where'd you
find him he's in memphis tennessee still
very much alive holiday ends
he drives in the early 50s he drives to
washington from memphis he's a home
builder with his wife and he's annoyed
because they've got a couple kids with
them and everywhere they go the motels
are still pretty primitive you have to
check out the motel you go is it okay is
it clean is or is it sleazy as some
motels were want to be in those days
and then you have to pay a dollar extra
for each child and he's furious and he
vows to his wife when i get back the
first thing i'm going to do is i'm going
to go in business and build a chain of
400 hotels and she said you know you're
just crazy
well he does it he and he's a home
builder so he knows how to build
something big which is that the cost
is you know in the in the plumbing and
the windows but if you make it big it's
not that much expect more expensive so
he does this he has a sketch he sketches
it out an architect friend looks at it
finishes it off and comes back with a
big sign that says holiday inn
and kevin says where'd you get that
says well i was watching the movies
while i was finishing i was watching
this movie you know bing crosby and so i
put it on there from that comes the
holiday inn
chain
with
thousands of motels and he becomes
brilliant at going to every city with a
little plane and spotting the entryways
and where to put his motel right on the
outside at just the right junction with
just the right approach so that the sign
can be seen an american genius an
american original
of all those people that you track down
at your list in the back that you've
interviewed which one do you remember
the most i mean who are some of the
interesting characters i think bill
levitt i mean here's i mean you talk
about the american revolution of
affluence the coming of this if we're
talk this book is a little bit about the
century of the ordinary man the common
man where the common man
lives as the wealthy have
lived in the past i mean we take middle
class affluence for granted today
but it wasn't always that way i mean
but it began in the 50s never was there
a country so rich and never was there a
country which shared its wealth so
equitably and probably the great enabler
of that signature figure is bill leavitt
who does this mass-produced housing i
mean he's really a lineal descendant of
the first henry ford who does
mass-produce cars assembly line cars and
the worker for the first time can buy a
car the worker as consumer
bill levitt takes it a second uh an
additional way he takes it into
mass-produced housing well you can't
have houses roll down the assembly line
they're too big so he does something
different he brings the workers to the
site
and the site is the assembly line and
then each day a different group goes out
and does one of about 21 functions boom
boom boom 18 houses finished in the
morning 18 houses finished in the
afternoon 180 houses and really well
built
finished at the end of a week and they
are good and they are sturdy and you can
get them with a hundred dollars down mr
veteran says the ad you're a lucky guy
with a hundred dollars now you can get a
a levitt house where'd you find him i
found him with about four phone calls
couldn't find him couldn't find him
finally a lawyer friend of mine who had
worked for him in the past found him i
interviewed him came by my home could
not have had a better day i think if
he's a if there's a hero in the book it
may be william levitt i mean we're
talking about an era of affluence the
century of a common man where the
ordinary person has dignity affluence
and the fruits of his labor as has never
happened in the history of mankind other
societies have followed us europe now
the japanese now the beginning of it in
korea but we were the first and one of
the great enablers
someone like bill levitt how old is he
god i think he's probably in his early
80s now where does he live he lives in
long island
who else anybody else that they remember
well i like the mcdonald brothers i
think they're wonderful are these guys
who
haven't made very much of a success in
american life and then one day they open
this little place out in san bernardino
and they begin to do well but they begin
to check their menu out i mean they
don't have they don't have any computer
but they start checking out what works
and they figure out
you know it's time to narrow
the menu nobody's buying the barbecue
they get rid of paper they get rid of
plates and silverware they get rid of
the girls the carhop girls because
people stick around too long for these
pretty girls and they begin to mechanize
the process of the american hamburger
and the bigger they become geniuses
stainless steel grills
a stainless steel thing that you can
squirt ketchup just the right dollop of
ketchup out i mean they begin they have
a friend who's an inventor they tell him
their problems and he goes out and does
it and suddenly they have assembly line
hamburgers 15 cents
and they're making each is making a
hundred thousand dollars a year and then
ray kroc and amer another american
genius comes and decides to franchise it
becomes their franchise
and the mcdonald's really aren't very
interested in franchising they don't
want more wealth they're very happy with
what they have are they alive one is did
you talk to him yes i did mac mcdonald
yes he was wonderful to talk to he's a
wonderful man where'd you find him he's
up in new hampshire
the people out at mcdonald's helped
point me find him i thought he was the
average man
i think he's got you know he said i
could have been a lot richer but if i
were a lot richer i'd have a lot more
problems i'd be up in the top floor some
40
40-story building and i'd be surrounded
by nothing but tax lawyers and i don't
want that i made all the money i needed
you know they would they make about 100
000 a year and the first thing they did
each year was what the in those days the
wealthiest man in every town did he took
his one-year-old cadillac plus seven
hundred dollars and turned it in for a
brand new cadillac that's what you did
in the fifties
said we come back to television and
politics the alger hiss
whitaker chamber hearings were televised
but you say
this was the first
national politician that was the first
there was almost not even national it
was a small network of
hookups i think new york boston
washington and philadelphia the hiss
thing was really i don't know that it
was really televised in any real sense
but with this you had the first moment
where there's frank costello being
accused of being a mob guy and they had
the camera on him
and he says i don't want the camera on
me
so they put the camera on his hand and
you can see his hand nodded you see them
sweating i mean it is a dramatic moment
in the power of television this is 1951
the next year estes kefauver is a
serious candidate for the presidential
nomination and you get a quick sense of
the power of television
what did television do for
richard nixon
well it got him it kept his place on the
ticket when there was a slight scandal
was a fund that some wealthy backers in
california had created for him the
alleged slush fund i think it was pretty
small goods but he was he had these
charges and suddenly there was ike who
had been promised to clean up the
corruption in uh in washington and he
gives this idea of a of a houndstooth
club that nixon has to be cleaner than a
hound tooth and with that uh nixon
defends himself in this
quite
uh
in his speech the nix the checkers
speech where he sort of says i you know
pat has a cloth coat and it's a
republican cloth coat and she'd look
good in anything it's quite a bit of
bathos in that and he sort of he opens
up their checkbook he says how poor they
are she who has fought this draconian
poverty hates it she hates the checkered
speech she hates revealing how poor
they've been and how hard their lives
have been but he wins his place back on
the ticket with this speech is that
where you write about the shave stick
that's no that's the kennedy nixon
debate where you know nixon sort of like
i do has a very dark beard and a light
uh skin
and he arrives in chicago it's the
climactic moment of the book the end of
the decade and he's going to debate john
kennedy
and there's a great question of which
you know will they use makeup and nixon
neither wants to use makeup and then
find out the other guy hasn't used it
well unfortunately nixon has a pale skin
dark beard and he looks sick anyway
because he's been ill his clothes hang
on him kennedy comes in and he looks
wonderful he's been out campaigning in
california so he has this great you know
tan
and nixon is very sensitive to lights
and suddenly in the middle of the of uh
the debates the heat the you see rivers
of
sweat washing down the cosmetic it's
kind of a cosmetic meltdown on his face
and he in effect loses the televised
debate my friend russ baker says it's
the moment in america where images
replace words as the currency of
american
politics and it it is and also what he
loses in this because you have to
remember when he goes into the debate
he's not only the famous
vice president and a famous debater
because he's debated khrushchev earlier
but he's been vice president of the
united states for eight years so the one
thing he has
is his great experience whereas kennedy
is allegedly this young junior senator
to callow too young when it's over
that debate has brought kennedy to peer
position we nixon loses his eight years
of expertise as vice president in that
night and from then on he's fighting
defensively to stay uh stay alive
haven't got much time so this has been
fun
little things uh this isn't so little
really uh the 13 books you've written is
there one that's
sold more than all the rest well i think
this one's understandable i mean as even
as we talk it's number one on a bunch of
lists and i think it's the right book at
the right time and i mean i sort of
sensed that about a year ago when i saw
the wonderful response to uh david
mccullough's
wonderful book on truman i had a sense
of the book on the 50s was probably the
timing was going to be good there's a i
have a small book that i did about four
young men rowing for an olympic medal
that i really love you know when you ask
someone which of your books do you
prefer it's sort of like asking somebody
with a large family which of your
children do you love the most but
sometimes in your family you have a
child that's not as big as the others
and not as famous and whatever but you
know that that child has the sweetest
heart and the little book i did call the
amateurs about these four young men
rowing is my inner my secret favorite
as you went about researching the 50s
and charles van doren wouldn't talk to
you were there others that you would
have liked to there were a couple times
i think where i didn't get much response
or people didn't respond in some cases i
think they were very old i mean some of
the people who were players were in
their 80s but i i
think of it myself generally as having
very good access i mean i it's a lovely
time in my life i mean you you know you
spend 30 35 years building a
constituency and doing things and
suddenly it seemed to me that it all
came home with this book i mean i do a
section on the emmett till trial and the
coming of mass journalism at the emmett
till trial in 1955 and that's that was a
section i've been trying to write for
some 35 years i as a young reporter i
tried to write a magazine piece about
all these reporters coming down to write
this to cover this trial and i didn't
have the skill to pull it off i finally
pull it off 35 years later 38 years
later in this book
what's the best thing in the last minute
we've got that somebody can come up to
you and say somebody you don't know and
i assume you get that all the time what
what what
when you walk away from somebody that
just met you and they've said things to
you what's the best thing they can say i
think if someone came up and said listen
i really not only liked your book
but it made me understand
where the country was then and in the
60s and more importantly why we have
some problems today
if someone says your book has informed
me and allowed me to understand
where we are as a country and what
happened then and why and why we have
different problems now then you think
you you know you're trying to be a part
of an informed society
you're trying to help a society
know that it has a compass and use that
compass well and if i can be part of
finding true on the compass and that's
an ongoing struggle finding true on the
compass for a society as large as
contentious as diverse as our as ours
then you've done your job well
this is what the book looks like it's by
david halberstam and it's called the 50s
thank you very much sir
[Music]
david halberstam's latest is the
teammates
the 50s is available in paperback from
fawcett books and imprint of random
house visit randomhouse.com for more
information
next week on